the state of georgia set an all-time
record for the number of votes cast
during this election and this morning
those votes are still being counted
right now president-elect joe biden is
leading president trump in the
traditionally red state by more than 12
thousand votes
and many are crediting the efforts of
the one woman one woman in particular
the state's former house minority leader
stacey abrams mark strossman is in
atlanta where he spoke with abrams about
rallying voters mark good morning to you
good morning we're showing this mural of
stacey abrams because
it seems timely this is clearly stacy
abrams moment
in this recent election a million more
georgians voted than four years ago
and voter registration on that scale is
clearly a team sport
but the captain of that team is stacy
abrams
please welcome back to a late show
stacey abrams
suddenly it seems everybody stephen
colbert included
wants to talk to stacy abrams are you
allowing yourself
time to celebrate right now or is there
too much work to be done i had about 17
minutes on
saturday afternoon i'm good good evening
my fellow americans
much of america met her last year giving
the democratic response
to president trump's state of the union
address but it was last week when
abrams really made her mark nearly five
million georgians voted a record joe
biden's poised
to win here he should thank abrams and
new georgia project
they've helped register 800 000 new
voters in georgia
a stunning number mostly in communities
of color
we knocked on doors in pockets of
communities that had never been touched
and we kept coming back is there anyone
else in your family who needs to
register
what about your neighbors stacy abrams
now 46
graduated from spelman college and yale
law school
she became a state rep and eventually
george's house minority leader
but her passion since she was 17
fighting voter suppression
barriers to the ballot politicians
believe their way to preserve their
power
is to impede the ability of voters to be
heard and typically they target
people of color young people and they
target the poor
in 2018 abrams ran for governor in
georgia
barack obama endorsed her oprah winfrey
campaigned for her
but the year before this republican-run
state slashed nearly 670 thousand voters
from its roles
nearly 70 percent of them black
george's secretary of state overseeing
the purge
republican brian kemp who was abram's
opponent
in the governor's race she lost by 55
000 votes
so you've never conceded that race
because you believe it was stolen from
you
no i believe it was stolen from the
voters i just said it can't happen again
and that has been my mission for the
last two years after that loss
abrams founded another group fair fight
in this recent election it worked to
blunt voter suppression
in 20 states we were in michigan we were
in wisconsin we were in north carolina
we were in pennsylvania voter
suppression happens anywhere
do you think you're helping change the
trajectory
of the democratic party we changed not
only the trajectory
of georgia we changed the direct the
trajectory of the nation
because our combined power shows that
progress is not only possible it is
inevitable
abram's next challenge is the super bowl
of runoffs in january
georgia will elect both its u.s senators
control of the senate itself hangs in
the balance
people will do almost anything when they
know success is likely
it is the actual thing that can change
the future
and i believe they'll show up
showing you this mural one more time at
the very top of the building someone
repainted it you can see the names
ossoff and warnock they are the two
democratic candidates running for u.s
senate
who are bracing next january's a runoff
election
something else to consider here if
you've ever been to atlanta you've often
seen
murals of congressman john lewis the
late civil rights icon
abrams told me that his deathbed plea
was go vote exactly i keep hearing that
story mark did
stacy say anything about a possible
position in the
biden administration because i've heard
people say what is stacey abrams want
whatever the hell she wants
ambassadorship
has she said anything at all about that
may be too pretty
the focus honestly gail at this point is
is this january runoff i mean they see
that as so critical
and they they honestly believe they
honestly believe that now that they've
proved to people that
if you register and you vote you can
make a difference it'll be much easier
to get them to vote again
runoffs typically turnout is not as good
as the general election
they're really hoping to sustain that
momentum because they know that
republicans here
are really going to bring all possible
weapons to bear on
keeping control of the u.s senate by
winning both of these u.s senate seats
well i know she's all over that race but
there is a bit of a republican versus
republican drama mark
you've got senator kelly loffler and
david perdue who are involved in those
runoffs
calling for the resignation of georgia's
republican secretary of state
because they say this election was an
embarrassment do you think this
this this movement has any legs anything
to this
i mean they're they're turning on each
other gail because th
they're looking for a way to put the
president over the top
by all accounts this recent election
record turnout new machines went very
very smoothly
there has been zero proof and i mean
zero of widespread
irregularities here i mean nothing at
all seems to be consistent about what
we're hearing nationwide too
thank you very much mark strassman
always good to see you
in atlanta georgia